sorry can I just add a caveat so you
wouldn't pick the idea of legacy
like your your loins being passed down
being able to kind of have I don't know
yeah honestly bro I do not know many
people in happy relationships and I know
people in relationships so cool you've
made kids whatever but
you're fundamentally you're not that
happy and the thought of that Legacy is
not what's carrying you life is
literally carrying you you understand
you have to provide and you have to look
after your family but you're genuinely
not happy now
living that Hugh Hefner lifestyle there
will be moments where you think this
might get a bit boring but then you will
get strong again and you'll have an
abundance of beautiful women to deal
with
and you'll start feeling happy again I
feel you'll have more moments of
happiness than sadness in that situation
than in a family
orientation what I said sorry pulling up
hi Sarah Sarah pull up pull up we got 12
more hours
I guess like I just always had a really
good example of like marriage and my
parents and like the families around us
but I'm also a woman so I know like we
view things differently yeah but I don't
know like my parents my parents were
always like the cute ones growing up
like they were always the ones that were
like holding hands and like yeah like I
don't know like doing like cute [ __ ] but
you also know that that is very rare
like you not really where I'm from no
like I can think of like three four I
mean I wouldn't say it's like the I'd
say it's like 50 50 where I'm from what
is like families being like happy and I
mean Happy's relative so I'm not like
they're not teenager puppy like you know
like first year of dating love but it's
like
like overall I'd say they like each
other they're happy you know that's nice
yeah no but it's it's not the norm all
the time yeah that's my point yeah it's
like it's really not
you know so yeah I'm I'm getting huge
are you getting Hugh Hefner family
Legacy I'm going Playboy Bunny yeah yo I
can't lie to you
a big family man yeah yeah okay I'm fine
no I put family yeah but maybe I date a
virgin yeah no but that's probably on
the basis that I
the Hugh Hefner I have I've never
experienced having my own family in it
and I think ideally I my mindset would
be to like have the nuclear family and
try and see where that goes
um but
hit the Hugh Hefner lifestyle
yeah like
like I've seen it I you know what I mean
I've seen it I I know what it entails I
know what it looks like at the top right
not personally but I I've seen it I've
witnessed it I've been around it it's
like okay I know what I'm what it would
look like yeah I have an idea okay and
everyone like in fact the family would
be better yeah you think the same
for 50 years would be better I think the
same vagina
[Music]
we need to step out once or twice
the devil you know is better than the
one you don't I struggle to believe that
man I feel like
I don't I see the two and like I said I
I don't see many I mean we look at all
the debating we've done today and these
are from single people currently you
know yeah like to even find people in
relationships who could come and debate
they will not really tell you anything
positive about their relationships I beg
to differ we have a lot of people come
on yeah yeah okay what do they say
there's not a lot of them but we have
had people yeah yeah come on like
recently we had like one girl who
when she married her spouse they were
both virgins okay and she explained that
they're pretty happy in their marriage I
think they're newlyweds okay like it's
been going really well for them right
um
I don't know like we've had a variety of
people we've seen people that are quite
happy in their relationship so okay well
that's good man long may that country
but then again there are people that you
can tell they ain't talking too much
about the relationship yeah I'm in a
relationship but it's not well there's
there's some girls that like they'll say
they have a boyfriend they'll look at
their Instagram I'm like where is he
where is he yeah
but I don't know the you know what we
have had what a lot of girls that
I don't know you can tell they've
settled right like you they speak about
their boyfriend or
they're in that age category where we
know that they're going for the mating
strategy we've had a lot of like baby
Moms come on right
and they've got their guys and
you can tell it's not the guy they
wanted or like that baby that's not in
the picture anymore and you're like
this guy doesn't even know what's going
on exactly you know no clue it's funny
you say that because like I at my place
of work I've there are some girls who
are in relationship and just the way
they talk about their partner like if he
heard he would leave them
Woody though for me he wouldn't but he
should he should yeah just based on the
way they talk about them so it's like
yeah there is a lot of settling there is
a lot of I probably couldn't survive
financially without him you know
therefore he stays around but I always
feel like you know when you're talking
about your partner like that to other
people it's crazy no I head up crazy but
it happens a lot what's up everybody
girls she wants to tell the chat let us
know
makes sense
out here playing Captain Save A Hoe
okay you can't save these hoes
you know me
what nothing like it
[Music]
um question
so
you meet a girl you really like ish
would you get married and have kids now
if I met a girl I really like what I'm
getting married
yo if
did you get married and have kids like
now like next like three years
yeah yeah yeah yeah what about you want
to be married yeah that's the ultimate
goal okay but like he wants side chicks
is what I'm hearing
I would never cheat
black man black man don't cheat that's
right let them know
anyway this is like girls I don't need a
man yeah okay yeah okay
I saw the death in your eyes when you
said the same punani for 50 years
my man needs it how many side chicks you
need how many wives do you want I said
me and Jess are looking to be Sister
Wives just you know